let's talk about kyle rittenhouse
behold this image for those that are
watching on youtube it is the prosecutor
in one of the prosecutors in the car
written house case face palming
and this was when their own witness gage
gross kreutz admitted he only was fired
upon after he drew his gun on kyle and
then advanced on in the crazy thing
about this is that in the trial this guy
gage was lying over and over again and
the defense kept calling him out like
here's a signed statement here's a
photograph here's an image here's a
video and then only then was the dude
finally admitting what he was saying was
like okay and then like changing his
answer
in this instance he was asked by the
prosecutor by the defense sorry the
defense asked gage grosskroitz he's one
of the guys who attacked written house
and got and got shot and he the defense
said
it was only when you pointed the gun at
rittenhouse that he would that he fired
upon you and grosskroyd said no at first
so the defense pulls out a photo
gives it to him and he's like what's
that a photo of and he's like you're
pointing your weapon at written house
and then he's firing on you and then he
said it again so it was only after you
advanced on written house gun drawn
pointed at him that he fired on you and
that's when he goes yes
immediately all the pundits are like oh
directed verdict directed verdict it's
over
but um i don't know if it means it's
over it certainly means that on the
murder charges i think a fair assessment
would be written house is going to get
its self-defense but there's still the
weapons charge and cash interestingly
you are saying like you've tried cases
before and you think the jury might
actually what say we don't care about
this or look i tried like 60 jury trials
to verdict right criminal murders
homicides bank robberies narco
trafficking you name it right every case
i thought i was going to win i lost
every case i thought i was going to lose
i won
juries are and this is why there is no
such thing as jury specialist because
you cannot be that good at reading 12
total strangers
and and the the signs in this case are
good
but uh people are like well if a jury's
out for three days it means the defense
won't there are no rules for this stuff
i think this is a very good day for the
defense and also the fact that the
prosecutor in this case has his hand his
head in his hand his photo's amazing no
but just he means he did not prep his
key witness the major witness in the
case the victim because he's shocked to
have that verbiage come out during the
trial he's not a witness not a victim
not a victim sorry i'm a victim yeah he
was the star witness that planning
witness lied to the police lied about
exactly what happened here and now this
i mean some people are saying this is
this is over but as you said you know
court proceedings are like gambling you
never know what the outcome is going to
be and there's a lot of people
threatening uh riots a lot of people
threatening protests a lot of people
threatening to go after the jury as well
so we're having a lot of outside impact
on this very important trial that i
think we should also kind of hone in on
and talk about that's that that's crazy
to me though that i
people were saying uh it was like
requiered a law there's a viral video
that viva fry posted these are lawyers
by the way those aren't familiar with
them and wreck yet is like directed
verdict there it is on all murder
charges which basically means what can
you explain directed sure it's it's it's
this mechanism in in legal trials where
you basically you say judge did you just
see what happened there's so much
evidence to go our way our way being the
defense take the case out of the hands
of the jury direct the verdict because
the law cannot convict this man based on
the facts it's rarely used i agree with
the sentiment expressed by the attorneys
but a judge can also reserve a directed
verdict till after the jury even comes
back with their verdict so that's
generally what happens does that happen
often wow wow
less than one percent of the time so
you're saying the jury could actually
come back and be like he's guilty but
the judge could go no yep you can still
file your motion for directed verdict
afterwards because you can say the jury
error they're the they decide the fact
you judge decide the law and based on
the law you can't convict my client of
murder i i can't
i think it's insane this is even a trial
at this point
it's political it's the i was just gonna
say it's the politics and that's what
makes this trial even scarier it's the
politics of the case make it even
scarier because the jury is gonna feel
more pressure you know it's gonna be
kind of screwed up if i turn out to be
right because it was well what i mean is
a few weeks ago like a few months ago i
said kyle's going to get life
because
because what happened with the chauvin
trial is uh
you know we mentioned this a little bit
briefly before the show that they tried
they get him on murder and all that
stuff but it was like potentially
manslaughter that was the argument
and then during the court case it was
not just my opinion as a layman which is
not worth much at all but all these
legal analysts actual lawyers actual
defense lawyers saying like wow wow wow
in these instances but the jury was
under duress
so you end up with jurors coming in the
chauvin trial being brought in by armed
cops with machine guns
clearly something's wrong in that case
and then the jurors even said after the
fact they were scared they'd be targeted
i felt the same same way with the jurors
in the written house case no one is
going to want to stand up and stick
their neck out for this kid if a rioter
is going to show up and burn your house
down however now it's winter people
don't write in the winter as much like
it typically won't happen
now it looks like they over they
definitely overcharged written house and
so i'm starting to think that you know
after seeing how the judge was ruling on
this and how the state has been handling
it they've had three witnesses they've
called that have backfired on them you
had richie mcginnis who basically was
like the dudes had fu and tried grabbing
the gun and they tried
finagling their way out of that one you
had i think his name was ryan belch who
said
one of the one of the people who
attacked written house went up to them
earlier in the day and said if i catch
you alone i'll effing kill you
and that was the dis that was the state
that's a prosecution's witness and then
you get this guy who's like
suing the city for 10 million dollars
and he gets asked by the defense the
outcome of this case will impact whether
or not you win that money and he's like
yeah but he stopped short of saying he
thought you know convicting rent house
would help him win the money and then
you get this where he's basically like
you know i was only fired upon when i
pointed my gun
but what if the jury gets scared you
know there's a viral video where a guy
guy's like we got cameras in the
courtroom we know who these people are
what if the jury gets scared they split
the baby that's what they used to call
it basically the judge where the jury
comes in and says there's too much
political heat on this there's too much
media on this
if we are just deciding this case on the
facts and the law we'd probably acquit
him but we're not going to convict him
of murder we're going to go in between
and probably hit him with the
manslaughter charge that happens a lot
in high-profile media cases that's scary
that's not justice no it's the furthest
thing from it with with the chauvin case
i think it might have been will
chamberlain who who mentioned this you
know will yeah lawyer he was saying that
as soon as the judge
in that case acknowledged
there's nowhere you can go
where people won't know about the
rioting
he was like it should have been
dismissed the case outright if you can't
have a fair trial then you can't have a
trial yeah there's no good there was a
cost to move that venue move it out you
know and that's what he was alluding to
and
you know most judges won't do it
watching this this case with written
house
i mean
it's it's it feels like the prosecutor
is throwing it on purpose
i mean i think he's just he's just not
prepared he thought he looks to me like
a prosecutor when i was a public
defender of face guys like this who
thought i've got this case so in the bag
like the casey anthony prosecutors down
to miami i've got this case so in the
bag i literally don't have to do
anything to put up my witnesses and the
political shitstorm and the media will
come in and basically overcome my
failures
why do they want to prosecute written
house they've seen all the evidence well
again you're going back to justice right
which is a concept that's unfortunately
eroding in this country but basically
their their take is we've got to
prosecute this guy the media is going to
you know come after us if we don't
certain politicians will come after
certain factions of america will come
after us if we don't prosecute this
individual he's not has i don't know if
you know this but was kyle rittenhouse
charged with manslaughter he wasn't was
he you don't have to be
basically going to get to basically once
you're charged with the top crime you
can be convicted of everything
underneath it you know so murder
includes manslaughter there's probably
three different kinds of manslaughter it
includes aggravated assault and if you
use the weapon there's a firearms charge
there's a whole litany of things that
comes in underneath so what do you think
you think he's going to get a lesser
charge yeah
man that's bs what do you i hope i'm
wrong yeah what do you think about human
events reporting that the fbi allegedly
had footage of exactly what happened
here but they didn't want to release it
because they didn't want to exonerate
written house that's that's the
allegations by human events wow that so
look having been a guy who was a
national security prosecutor
prosecuted terrorists all over the world
and worked with the fbi i love those
guys most of them right what i don't
like is the top and that russia gate
we'll get to that as a prime example of
how
america's faith in our law enforcement
community has been destroyed by a select
few and when you say something like that
if you told me that seven years ago i'd
be like you're crazy man if you tell me
that today i'd be like someone needs to
do that someone needs to look into that
seriously because if the if the justice
department withheld evidence exculpatory
evidence like we've caught them doing
time and time again from russiagate on
through the flynn case when flynn was
exonerated they withheld the excludatory
evidence day of the fbi well the epstein
case they withheld the information for
30 plus years the fbi was was
interviewing witnesses in the 90s that's
right with women that came forward and
said hey this is happening and the fbi
literally looked the other way there was
the other case of the other um
family-friendly show the other person
who hurt children i forgot his name we
were just talking about that prince
andrew
there's of course percentage and then
there's another
there's another case a couple weeks ago
where the fbi again ignored the victims
uh screwed them when they knew oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh
yeah
nasser so yeah so
it's like how many times could they do
this now dude dude yeah
i'm watching the live stream of this
case
and i think anybody who's watching this
is probably asking themselves over and
over again how was gage gross kreutz not
criminally charged for it for for at
least the having the gun right but it
sounds like attempted murder potentially
the
the only reason that we're not watching
a trial is being uh for attempted murder
is that kylo ren has defended himself
gage gross croits lied to the police
multiple officers about having a gun
he his concealed carry was invalid he
knew it was invalid so he lied to the
police
so here he is
at a protest he goes at a riot he goes
to multiple he's admitted this on the
stand multiple events armed with a gun
he's not legally allowed to be carrying
now i'll stop right there and say i
believe he that that's a bunk claim
because the constitution says you're
right to keep and bear arms and then
trying to put this this law over
someone's right keeping bear arms is bs
but for the sake of the statutory legal
issue at play here's a guy who should
have been charged for bringing an
illegal weapon concealed to a riot on
multiple occasions and the prosecution
showed that he was chasing kyle
rittenhouse out of view of written house
he didn't know where kyle was and you
can see him on camera running towards
him and reaching into the small of his
back and drawing the gun from his
waistband
how did this guy not get charged thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time